[Applause]
it's a major victory but not for the
reasons
julian assange and his supporters had
hoped
the judge blocked his extradition to the
united states
because he was a suicide risk not
because he was justified in publishing u
s government secrets
the wikileaks founder has been kept in
custody pending an appeal
i had hoped that today would be the day
that julian would come home
today is not that day but that day will
come soon
ten years ago assange published
thousands of leaked classified us
government documents
military and diplomatic most notoriously
it included footage of u.s troops firing
on and
killing civilians during the iraq war
[Applause]
in a series of legal battles assange was
originally arrested on sex allegations
from sweden
those charges were later dropped he
fought extradition and lost
and then for seven years was given
asylum in london's
ecuadorian embassy when that asylum was
withdrawn two years ago
he was arrested and jailed for jumping
bail
only then did the americans file spying
charges against him
and demand his extradition the judge
decided assange would not survive an
american jail she said
i am satisfied the procedures described
by the u.s
will not prevent mr assange from finding
a way to commit suicide
and for this reason i have decided
extradition would be oppressive
by reasons of mental harm and i order
his discharge
the judge rejected his main defense that
he had acted simply
as any investigative journalist this
wasn't
a victory for journalism in fact the
judge said
he had put people's lives in danger
sacrificing their safety
in the name of free speech what a
moment a glimpse of hope
to start the new year and hopefully a
new era
it is a day a day
with win for julian assange
but we have to be cautious it is not
necessarily a win
for journalism on wednesday assange's
lawyers will ask the judge
to free him on bail while the u.s
government launches an appeal
in a new attempt to get him extradited
martin brunt's sky news at the old
bailey